why do you think that there's so many
people who believe the world's
doomed I think because we're facing a
pretty broad range of what are
potentially existential are very
catastrophic problems so like from my
domain the big one is is climate change
and that's what I write about most of
all but there's also other ones there's
nuclear war there's the rise of AI I
think there's now a host of problems
that in the past might not have seemed
existential but to many people today
seem very existential
if you are knee deep in the data why
aren't you in
agreement so I can't speak on AI or or
nuclear war but my background is
environment and and climate change um
and I think actually probably I was in
the similar position you know a decade
ago or so ago um where I did really feel
like in the depths of there's no way
that we're going to solve this problem
this is an existential problem we are
all kind of doomed um and I think that
was a lot of the the message that was
coming through my perspective on that
has changed not that climate change
isn't a big problem it is that's why I
study it but there's a really broad
spectrum between climate change is not a
problem and we're all doomed and there's
nothing we can do about it I think
there's a big space in the middle and
that big space in the middle is
determined by what we do about it so I
think like my stance on it is it's a big
problem and it's an urgent problem but
there actually are things that we can do
about it and there are ways that we can
adapt to a changing climate when it
comes to climate change in particular
why are more people
pessimistic about the world than the
data suggests that they maybe should
be I think one of the key un
misunderstandings on climate is that you
know we've kind of set these climate
targets that we want to keep temperature
rise below 1.5 degrees if we can and
especially below two degrees now I think
some of the message that's come out of
that is that you know 1 Point 5 degrees
is this Tipping Point where once we're
past 1.5 degrees or it's kind of the
point of no return and we're doomed and
that's that's definitely not the case
climate change is more of a spectrum
than an immediate Tipping Point so 1.5
degrees the impacts are worse and at 1.6
they're worse again and 1.7 and you can
get escalating risks where the the
change is not necessarily linear with
every 0.1% degree but there's nothing
particularly special about 1.5 degrees
so I think I think is very clear that we
probably we are going to pass 1.5° but
if your mindset is that once we're past
1.5 deges there's nothing we can do and
it's kind of aernal Tipping Point then I
think that breeds a lot of this kind of
apocalyptic thinking what is the what's
legit and what's about tipping
points and stuff so there are big
tipping points uh where in the kind of
climate system there are we don't know
um there are like a lot of unknowns
about when we might hit a Tipping Point
and what that Tipping Point would be
there are some potential like quite
near-term tipping points where you're in
the kind of between 1.5 degrees and two
degrees range there are a couple of
tipping points that that could be
breached what what happens what what do
people mean when they talk about tipping
points from a like functional climate
functional perspective so I think the
the the kind of definition of a Tipping
Point is that you kind of change a
system from one state into another and
it's very hard if not impossible to take
it back from that now I think one of the
misunderstandings of tipping points is
that people think that it's kind of
abrupt and immediate that you know it's
almost like a a domino effect whereas
it's once it's set off it's like within
a year the whole thing kind of blows up
and I think some tipping points can be
fast but often they're quite slow on
kind of human time scales so some of
these tipping points will evolve over
you know centuries or or thousands of
years it's not just like the entire ice
sheet just immediately melts in the
space of a year um so I think that's one
of the the key differences there um but
there are some near near term potential
tipping points where you will shift the
system into a different state and that
will contribute to more warming um but
it won't necessarily set this like this
full chain where you know it's kind of
Unstoppable and there's nothing we can
do about it well this is one of the
common talking points around uh coastal
cities Miami Miami is going to be
underwater uh if we go over this it I'm
going to guess that Miami may be
underwater but in 1,200 years not like
2030 yeah some of the some of I mean
there is the sea levels are rising and
they're rising at a pretty steady rate
that could accelerate yeah but a lot of
the The Very extreme level rise
scenarios tend to be on the order of of
centuries for example extreme takes
Century so we at least there's a a
little bit you a time to yeah yeah I
mean I think the the risk of sea level
rise around coastal cities is is very
valid um and there are there could be
some near-term displacements um but a
lot of them could be on a longer time
scale than we imagine I read an article
from you where you said many young
people feel like their future is in
Peril to make progress on climate change
we must move past doomsday scenarios
why because I think it lows us into a
kind of state of paralysis like I speak
to a lot of young people people a lot of
people email me and they're in a very
dark place they're in a place where they
don't even know whether they should go
to college they don't know whether
should actually invest in the future
because they've kind of received the
message that there's no point because
they're kind of doomed from climate
change and I think one thing that's just
like bad for people's mental health but
I think the second is it I think it
paralyzes us and and stops people from
taking action like if we're doomed then
what's the point in actually taking
action against it so I think in some
ways it hinders progress
and uh in terms of taking action and
then I think there's another dimension
to it where I think some of these really
extreme scenarios have been used by
people on the other end so kind of more
on the climate denial end when they see
the really extreme scenarios it's just
like the perfect ammunition they just
think oh this is so ridiculous um and so
often like pushes people away at the
other end of the spectrum that might
normally engage yeah it seems
like in an attempt to try and convince
people that this is something we need to
pay attention to something which is
important which needs resources and time
and and and energy spending on it uh
that encouragement to try and get people
to work harder is done by
overexaggerating uh or or creating um
more catastrophe where there perhaps
isn't quite so much but the actual
reality is it just makes people sad and
anxious and believe that their efforts
are futile which is like from a net
effect is actually the opposite of what
you want right I mean I think that I
mean there's also like a really broad
spectrum in communication I mean I many
most climate scientists are very good on
the communication they're very careful
about how they communicate I think that
often messages are are weaponized by
some people and actually they put in
front of it the science says and they
say a statement that the science doesn't
say um and I think think for some people
probably a small segment of the the
population that actually does work that
does that fear does drive them they do
get involved but I think there's like a
much larger part of the um that that
that that puts them off yeah I watched
um a video that you spoke about in that
article from Roger ham founder of
Extinction Rebellion uh the video is
titled advice to young people as they
face
Annihilation hardly inspiring stuff no
and I me and he kind of a big point of
the video I think he says like young
people should just have no hope for the
future um and that's that's not in line
with the science I mean the science is
very clear that the climate change is a
big problem there are really big
potential risks but you know it's not a
an all or nothing like there are things
that we can do about it so this the
notion that we should have no hope
because there's nothing we can do is
just false what was that story of the
group called the last
generation yeah so there's an activist
group um I think in Germany called the
last generation and I think the the
message there can be interpreted in
several ways I think one is like very
valid which is we can be the last
generation to solve climate change and I
think that's true um that you know we're
talking about solving climate change
we're talking about you know the next
few decades or 30 or 40 years so kind of
yes we are this the generation that will
have to to solve this but I think the
other interpretation is kind of this
notion that if we don't solve it then we
will literally be the last generation
and that's very similar to the kind of
Extinction Rebellion uh activist group
where it is very much geared towards we
will be
kind of the last generation and were
kind of doomed yeah and they did a
monthlong hunger strike that resulted in
a ton of them going to hospital yeah
yeah there was a hunger strike yeah yeah
uh so when it comes to climate change
what are the what are the most Salient
concerns that you have and what are the
ones that you think are uh most
exaggerated or most
misrepresented so I think for me there
are a few big concerns one is just
exposure to heat I mean I think they
just the
very the most obvious and and and most
well documented link between Rising
temperatures is just exposure to extreme
heat waves um as you would expect and I
think that will be a significantly
growing problem it'll be also be a
really big problem because many of the
people that will be exposed to this will
be people closer to the Equator
typically claim lower income countries
where they don't you know have an air
conditioned house um so it tend will
also fall disproportionately on on
people on Lower incomes where they might
not have the money and luxuries that we
would have to just adapt to that I think
then the other big concern for me is is
agriculture where we've got a growing
population climate change there could be
a significant problem one in terms of
extreme weather events so floods
droughts you could lose like a whole
Harvest um for an entire season but also
crops and it varies across the world
depending on where you are and and what
crop you're working with but increased
temperatures could start to reduce
yields so some of the kind of scenarios
you could see for example a 30% drop in
yields now at time when we need to be
increasing food production because we
will have a growing population that
could be a significant concern so for me
those are the two like biggest direct
impact I think what about the efforts
that have been made over the last few
years you know it's not just now that
people have started talking about
climate change even if maybe the uh
discourse is getting more heated all the
time um it's not like this is a new
thing and there's been many initiatives
that have been put in in the UK in the
US trying to counter this how effective
or ineffective have those been I think
we are getting there we're just not
getting there fast enough I think people
have the notion that we're still in the
same position on tackling climate change
as we were a decade ago and I think
that's not true I think I think what's
re what's really fundamental to
addressing climate change is that humans
need energy right they need energy for
development and that has been a massive
driver of human progress over the last
few centuries so our basis of producing
energy has been fossil fuels now in
order to tackle that there are billions
of people still trying to move out of of
poverty still trying to increase their
energy use quite validly um and they're
they're not going to stop doing that
like you're not going to stop them doing
that so you need a substitute there a as
a substitution exercise you need to
substitute fossil fuels with a low
carbon energy source now the problem in
the past has been that these energy
sources were way too expensive right so
you never going to use solar or wind or
batteries or electric vehicles because
they were just way more expensive than
fossil fuels what's been a really
dramatic change especially in the last
decade is that the prices of these have
plummeted um so you know they not
electric cars are growing now and
they're getting very cost competitive
with petrol or or diesel cars but they
were really far away a decade ago uh
same with solar and wind they were
extremely expensive they're now
undercutting the cost of fossil fuels
now that's completely and fundamentally
changed the position that we're in
because we're no longer asking people to
make a tradeoff of do you want to escape
energy poverty or do you want to keep
your SE CO2 emissions low cuz like they
were always going to move out of energy
poverty I think we've reached a position
now where there's no longer that trade
of such that often people just go for
the low carbon energy source because
it's the cheapest I think to me that's
fundamentally changed the equation so
the overall story on carbon emissions
there is that rich countries over the
last few decades have tended to reduce
their emissions whereas middle and
low-income countries are are still
growing there so we kind of this tug of-
War at the global level which means that
global emissions are kind of now
hovering around a
peak yeah I think this
is I don't know this sort of
uh
uh the fact that we have a
shared environment but individual actors
acting independently of each other to
contribute to it means that there is
always going to be this sort of push and
pull right there is going to be a group
of people in developed countries that
are going to be told you need to reduce
energy emissions and it's very easy to
say Well they're not they're not going
to do it and yeah this what's it called
the tragedy of the commons um yeah it
there is always going to be some
equivalent of a free rider problem or or
something else it's it's always going to
be there and I think it's always going
to make people feel uncomfortable about
making sacrifices I
guess if they were to go and live in a
country that didn't have access to
Reliable energy or was burning wood or
dung to be able to do it they might
think uh maybe I'm not making that much
of a sacrifice but you know humans
are creatures of Relativity right we
have anchoring biases like I remember
how much my refrigerator energy fee was
last year and I've seen it go up this
year or I've been told that I can't
water my garden or whatever like you
know we we anchor off where our
lifestyle was previously not off someone
in the
Sudan right and I think yeah I think
that's been a a a key stumbling block
has been these divisions I think for me
there's there's so much finger pointing
in this it's kind of young people
pointing at old people or old people
pointing at young people or left
pointing at right and right pointing at
left and and rich countries pointing at
China or India and I think that's
created a lot of Divisions I think in
general what's worked better on climate
is that the way International climate
processes used to work was it was a very
like top down where basically there was
kind of global um Coalition and they
kind of would set try to set tar OS
targets from the top down and actually
it didn't get us that far and countries
didn't really like it what's actually
been more successful has country it's
been like a bottom up exercise where
countries have decided this is the the
the pledges or the targets that we're
going to put on the table and they
nominate it themselves now you might
think well they'll all just not put
anything on the table and to some extent
there's much room for them increasing
these these promises and we we hope they
do but you do start to get like a little
bit of a competition exercise where it
does start to put pressure on different
countries um so I think the the bottom
up approach of of people volunteering
what they're willing to do has actually
counterintuitively worked better than a
top down this is what you have to do and
I think in general that also works at
the the individual level I think the I
think there's a lot of push back against
people trying to tell others what you
should and shouldn't do often that's
like the best way to get someone to do
exactly what you don't want them to do
is to is to try to force them to do it
yeah what
uh I I'm interested in this stat that
you put up about um in the UK carbon
emissions per person a half what they
were when our grandparents were our age
and we haven't just offshored all of
these either that seems like quite a big
win yeah so carbon emissions in the UK
have fallen a lot they've Fallen by
around
50% um a big Big Driver of that has been
the reduction of coal so like most of
our electricity used to come from coal
and we're basically now coal free so
we've kind of got rid of the kind of the
dirtiest fuel in our electricity Mi mix
which has pushed down emissions a lot
now the caveat there is that the 50%
like exaggerates the total amount of
reductions that we've incurred because
we've offshored some of them so um we've
kind of got rid of a lot of our
manufacturing Industries so like we
import goods from other countries that
produce them and it's very valid to say
that you know the UK's carbon footprint
should be what the UK consumers are
actually consuming so the the the total
drop on that basis is not as big as 50%
but there is still a decline and
Emissions are still falling and that's a
kind of General Trend that we see across
most high income countries that domestic
emissions have reduced um but they've
also reduced when we take offshore R
into account got you how difficult is it
going to be to provide a good quality of
life for 8 billion people while still
being SU
sustainable it's a big challenge um yeah
it's going to be big I think it's
achievable I think I think for me what's
key is the time scale I think it's just
inevitable that we will just move to
clean energy I think how long we take to
do that will be the big question and
that will be the big question about what
temperature rise we we get to can we do
it in the next 30 Years um it will be a
big challenge but I would expect that we
would do it in the next 50 or 60 years
so the the emphasis is the on the speed
um which is going to be very difficult
but to me is not completely
unachievable what do people mean when
they talk about
degrowth so I think there's two terms
here I think one is focused on
population so it's more like
depopulation so kind of an
environmental movements a big especially
in the past uh like a big point was the
problem is just there's just too many
people
um and and the the planet cannot
possibly provide for so many people so
the solution to this problem is to have
less people and then there's more of a
kind of degrowth movement where the
argument there is that the driver has
been over consumption and therefore in
order to reduce our emissions we need to
basally shrink our
economies right and what are your
thoughts on
degrowth my thoughts are you cannot do
degrowth at a global level because you
would leave billions of people in
poverty and that's to me just morally
unacceptable and you just won't achieve
it right like you're not going to stop
people in low-income countries from from
trying to move out of poverty now
there's a question of should
you keep GDP and rich countries the same
or should you shrink the the economies
of rich countries I don't think that's
going to be a political reality like I
do not see any political leader standing
up and saying our main policy is that
we're going to reduce our economy in
order to reduce our CO2 emissions and
it's definitely not going to happen in
on the time scales that we're talking
about right we need to get moving on
this in the next decade um and to me I
do not see it being politically feasible
that that one that a leader would stand
up and promote that I think it would
kind of be political suicide um but also
that they would actually get elected
into government and then you've got the
long the long time period where even if
you did get that and people voted for it
and they went into government then
you've got the time that it takes to
actually Implement that and we don't
actually know how effective that would
be in reducing emissions like no one's
tried kind of deliberate degrowth so I
think there's like tons of unknowns
there and for me it's kind of a
political non-starter I guess over a
long enough time Horizon the next 100
years the people calling for
anti-natalist or depopulation they're
going to get the they're going to get
the outcome that they want it's just
going to happen due to declining birth
rates I know you know you made a really
good clarification at the very beginning
of this which is exist the difference
between existential risk and just you
know a big problem basically existential
risk permanent unrecoverable collapse
right it's a very specific category of
risk that shouldn't be thrown around
incorrectly uh and I don't think that
declining birth rates are one of those
either but they're definitely going to
be the sort of thing that will impact
human life front and center very very
harshly very quickly you know within
what when we going to Peak 2100 is 2019
I think the I think the the latest un
projections but was that it would global
population would Peak around 2080s um
and they've actually brought that
forward like the first project the late
the one prediction before that was you
know still increasing past 2100 and
actually because fertility rates which
is just the number of children that a
woman would have average woman would
have um is falling quicker than than we
expected that's actually what being
brought forward to the 2080s yeah so by
the end of this Century the degrowth
from a population standpoint I'm aware
that we're going to have to gain two
billion before we start to come back
down toward where we are now um but how
much How concerned are you about that
you know if we presume that what we're
trying to do here I don't know the basis
of your philosophy I don't know if it's
um seeing the Earth as something that
needs to be protected whether it's
trying to maximize human flourishing
whether it's trying to you know there's
a variety of reasons why people don't
want the world to go to um but if
we presume that in amongst that is the
flourishing utility udonia happiness of
the conscious humans that live on it
reducing that number down precipitously
is
dangerous it that doesn't seem to be in
alignment either so how much time do you
spend thinking about birth rates and
what's your concern with population
collapse um I don't spend much time at
all thinking about birth rates in a
climate context um and I don't think
it's affect Ive in any way to try to to
use climate or environment to to promote
lowering birth rates I mean I think the
basic story of falling fertility rates
and falling birth rates is that
um as countries develop as they get
richer as girls go to school women go
into education uh women go into uh
economic opportunities and jobs um
fertility rates tend to decline so you
see a very clear relationship that as
countries get richer they decline um
and the I think I think one of the key
part key parts of development is that
fertility rates will actually just
continue to fall the countries like
low-income countries where birth rates
are still quite high like maybe like
four or five or or six um those will
just fall because they will develop uh
kids girls will get to go to school
women will get going to work and and
have economic opportunities and I think
those are all fantastic developments
actually don't think you need the
climate lens as part of that I think if
your list of priorities of what would be
the driver of declining birth rate I
think climate change is very very low on
that risk like I'm I'm all for promotion
of girls going to school just because
they should have the opportunity to go
to school not because we should reduce
the population in order to address
climate change right okay that would be
that would be like a five-dimensional
chess move to try and uh speed up the
education of girls in low-income
countries in an attempt to reduce Dam
birth rates that would be that would be
an impressive strategy uh you said um I
saw another quote from you that said we
should use data to understand the world
and make better decisions that seems to
be like a nice tagline how effective
have you found data being at nudging
beliefs and culture and debate you are
part of this great website our world in
data and you put this stuff forward but
I would guess that the Vanguard like the
front lines of trying to convince people
by data might be more difficult than we
would think given that data is like
truth as long as it's right yeah yeah I
mean it's very mixed I mean I think
there are some people that are so immune
to data there's nothing there's no data
you could throw in front of them that
would make them change their mind and
there will always be you know an excuse
why that data doesn't fit with the
narrative or why that data is flawed um
I think some people are swayed by data
and can make good decisions based on it
um I think I mean a range of people use
our work like the general population use
our work but also journalists policy
makers use our work and then I think in
those fields data can actually make a
difference to inform decisions what's
happening with air
pollution so there have been a couple of
big air pollution problems there have
been a couple of what we'd call like
transboundary problems which is more
again the tragedy of the common problem
where it's not just you know pollution
in your own country it kind of crosses
across many countries um and you kind of
need you know several countries or the
whole world to work together to solve it
and one of the big ones there was the
ozone there so kind of before climate
change the big environmental problem was
the ozone layer and uh the growing ozone
hole and at the time it was really
politically controversial a bit like
climate change is today there were kind
of push back against scientists there
was um was really politically
controversial but we we actually managed
to to solve it like we we brought in
What's called the Montreal protocol and
we reduced the emissions of the gases
that were destroying the ozone layer by
like more than 99% so we've basically
got rid of them and the oone hole should
just repair itself in the next few
decades um there was another big problem
of acid rain which when you burn coal
you tend to produce what's called sulfur
dioxide and that can dissolve in
rainwater and you can get acid rain
again that was a big problem and we're
we've been pretty successful in solving
it especially across Europe and North
America and then there's the other
problem of what we call local Air
Pollution which is like the pollution
you'd find in your city uh from like
cars and burning fossil fuels and Home
Heating and stuff now the the story
there is mixed rich countries have gone
through this process where um as they
tended to get richer air pollution
increased so you if you think about
London or Edinburgh where I am um go
back to kind of the the beginning to Mid
20th century these cities were so so
polluted like really unimaginable from
what you would assume today I mean
there's stories of like you know the
Great Smog in London where you know you
couldn't see even see a few feet in
front of you they're kind of shuffling
trying to find the curb with their feet
so there these cities were incredibly
polluted and we've actually been really
successful over the last 50 years or so
and and dramatically reducing the amount
of local pollution uh especially in rich
countries it's a little bit of a
different story in low and middle inome
countries they're s of kind of going up
that curve that um London or Edinburgh
went through uh kind of 50 years to a
century ago um and air pollution in
general is a is a big killer in the
world so there are a range of estimates
but they're all in the range of kind of
millions of premature deaths per year so
is a is a a big big problem in some
sense you know today in terms of number
of lives lost it's arguably bigger than
climate change although that could
change in the future wow what do we do
how do you help air pollution
now you can I mean the key one is stop
burning fossil fuels um you can put kind
of
strict uh air pollution kind of
Standards on power plants like that was
the big thing of acid Rin like it's not
that we necessarily just stopped burning
coal we managed to put what called
scrubbers on the power plant where it
kind of took the sulfur out so you
didn't get the the sulfur emissions um a
big driver in in in rich countries has
been just increased uh air quality
standards for cars so the amount of um
of pollution spewing out the back of a
car today is much much less than it was
in the past and actually a move to
electric vehicles would would decrease
that even further so even in rich
countries you know the the estimated
deaths of contributed to air pollution
in the UK for example is still tens of
thousands so we know that we can still
bring down that down further and that
would be by for example moving away from
Petrol and and diesel cars what about
deforestation again it's a bit of a
story where countries tend to go through
a transition where they would initially
cut down forests for wood for energy
like before they have fossil fuels um
but then the biggest driver of
deforestation is just expanding Farmland
that's by far the biggest driver of
deforestation you need more land to grow
food therefore you you cut down forests
now uh the UK for example we cut down
our forests like a long time ago like
centuries and centuries ago and actually
there was really really very little
Forest left um but then we stopped doing
that and in many rich countries forests
are regrowing and most of the
deforestation that's happening today is
happening in the tropics and it's
happening because we're again we're
still expanding agricultural land
um so deforestation rates today are
still very very high but we think
they've Global deforestation rates have
fallen since around the 1980s but we we
still have a big challenge in our hands
because deforestation rates are still
high what's the truth about the cycle
between raising or Rising CO2 levels
with uh like regreening uh and the
increase in uh plant growth and tree
growth forest growth based on that
increase in carbon yeah there again it's
a little bit mixed in terms of like
Greening uh forests and natural habitat
not natural vegetation it can like extra
CO2 can increase um regrowth to an
extent I think this is often also
discussed in terms of Agriculture like I
was saying earlier that one of the big
risks of Agriculture is is climate
change and it is true that to a certain
extent more CO2 means can mean more more
higher yields and more crop growth but
it's about how much of that is
outweighed by the detrimental impacts of
drought of floods of temperatures and
for many crops The increased
temperatures will just outweigh the
increased benefits of CO2 so even if you
increase CO2 a bit you would still see
negative effects from uh the temperature
effects it's interesting that
everything's so Interlink here that for
instance deforestation is intrinsically
linked with food and hunger and Agri
culture so what progress has been made
with with uh food and hunger as well so
um I mean food and hunger again Global
hunger rates have declined substantially
over the last 50 years in particular
we've kind of plateaued and progress
there and actually in some regions that
has started to regress so we have around
800 million people in the world when
nearly one in 10 just don't get enough
food to eat and that's the key challenge
with with deforestation in these
problems is that again there you have
this tension between people just need
more food uh and we need more
agricultural land and there's World
habitat and there's forest in the way um
so that's the big challenge one of the
big solutions to that is just to make
agriculture much more productive right
so if you can increase crop yields by if
you can triple crop yields then you can
produce the same amount of food on a
thir of the land so one of the big uh
Necessities there is to just increase
crop yield and productivity and I think
in many regions there is still a lot of
scope to do that I think the the other
big link to deforestation there is like
animal agriculture so a lot of the
deforestation of the Amazon for example
is clearing land for pasture for cattle
grazing for beef production and by far
that's the biggest driver of
deforestation and in general beef is
just a really inefficient way of using
land to produce
food what what is the you talking about
crop yields there how much truth is
there in Top Soil degradation and and
the quality of what we're growing our
plants out of yeah so the I mean there's
been lots of headlines about you know
soil loss and there's this kind of like
we've only got the world's only got 60
Harvest left headline that kind of went
viral and that headline is not true and
kind of no so so scientist would back
that up across the world you have a
mixed again a mixed picture like some
soils are stable and and they are doing
fine some are actually growing so the
they're actually grow top soil is
growing and there are others that
actually are degrading over time and is
a serious worry but we're not going to
get to you know this you know single
point where you know just the the whole
in 60 years the world's Harvest just
stopped because of top soil there's just
a really large variation in soils across
the world where you could never just put
a single figure on when this would
happen H what about biodiversity that's
something else that I've seen talked
about an awful lot that the the fifth
great extension or the SE whichever one
we're in this is the beginning of six
whatever that one six sixth grade
Extinction we're in the middle of that
and we we've lost more species in the
last X number of years than in the whole
bigger number of years before that yeah
I mean bi the Trends on bioty
biodiversity loss are not good I think
they're like the area where I'm most
pessimistic so yeah there's been five
previous mass extinctions on Earth and
there's a question of like are we in the
six mass extinction now in order to to
qualify as like a mass extinction you
kind of have this threshold of you need
to lose like 75 to 80% of species and
you need to do it on a it's called a
fast time scale but it's like 2 million
years uh like it's fast on geological
time scales but on human time scills
it's obviously not um now we're
obviously very very far away from losing
that percentage of species but what you
can do is you can look at the rate of
change and say we know roughly how many
species have gone extinct over the last
few centuries for example um or or 500
years or a thousand years and you can
see okay what's the the rate of
Extinction there and then you can
compare that to what was the rate of
extinctions in the previous five mass
extinctions and actually what you find
when you crunch those numbers is that we
are actually losing species at a faster
rate than we were in the five previous
mass extinctions now if we just
continued to lose species at that rate
then yeah it would qualify as being in
the sex mass extinction um my optimism
there is that we won't just continue to
lose species of that rate because we
will hopefully address deforestation we
will hopefully curb climate change we
will hopefully be able to restore
natural habitats so this kind of I think
it's reasonably fair to say that you
know the trends Point towards a six Mass
iction if we just continue as we are but
my hope is that we won't continue as we
are what is driving this loss in
biodiversity was it coming
from I mean it's often referred to as
Death By A Thousand Cuts so there's no
like single driver of biodiversity loss
it tends to be a mix I mean the the
biggest driver is is food production so
it's either like either overall
exploitation which is just like direct
hunting or direct over fishing or kind
of logging of forest
um or it's destruction of habitats for
farming and Agriculture and that can be
either cutting down um forests or or
moving into wild grasslands but it can
also be you know losing insects uh
because of the use of fertilizer or
pesticides on agricultural land that's a
very to me that's a very very tricky
problem to solve because there's a kind
of there's kind of two camps on how you
produce food in a kind of biodiversity
friendly way like one you could just use
lots of fertilizers lots of pesticides
get really productive land you could use
less Land by doing that so basically say
we're going to accept that we're going
to have lots of biodiversity loss on
this smaller bit of land or you can go
for another approach where say we're
going to lose less biodiversity but
we're going to spread it over a larger
area and I think the kind of jury on
that is is still out on how best to
manage that yeah that's
a difficult a really difficult balance
to strike have you got any idea
what types of animals have contributed
most to this biodiversity loss has it
been segmented out has it been the fish
they're all falling off but mammals are
fine or is it mostly insects and
reptiles are fine have you got any idea
it's kind of mixed um like the mammals
are not doing well in particular I mean
if you look over the course of human
history the big change has been what we
call like the downsizing of mammals so
we've tended to just lose the big
mammals such that they're getting
smaller and smaller over time that's
because we predominantly hunt larger
animals um and they tend to go extinct
and they also take longer to reproduce
so smaller animals can kind of recover
because they can reproduce really
quickly whereas larger animals take much
longer so we've tended to lose the
largest mammals birds are not doing
particularly well neither are amphibians
um insects like the the general Trend
there is is not looking good I think
insects in general are just harder to
count is very hard to get really
long-term data on insects like you can
kind of count elephants like pretty well
and kind of get good historical records
but it's really hard to do for insects
go I think insects are pretty uncertain
but I think they're definitely in
Decline there very few very few like
good good Trends here on biodiversity I
was trying to find a a silver lining in
the by diversity loss but it doesn't
really seem to be there no I can give
you one like in some regions like Europe
for example we lost a lot of mammals but
we're actually bringing a lot of them
back now there's been lots of like
restoration
um uh programs and you know the European
bison is is on its way back so I think
there is stuff that you can do um and it
is possible to restore a lot of these
populations but the overall trend is
down I had a conversation a couple of
months ago with a guy who is bringing
woolly mammoths back to life right so
brand no no it wasn't I can't remember
the I can't remember the name of the
place Colossus colossum Colossus I think
uh is the name of the company and um
yeah they they've sequenced it from a
bunch of Frozen uh bone and I think
maybe something else samples uh and then
they're going to use
an Asian elephant maybe uh and they're
going to implant and then over time they
will have this and then maybe they can
go up North and they're at compacting
down the Earth and compacting down the
Earth changes the way that heat hits it
and then they help with fertilizing and
moving so that's and he also wanted to
do he had this really cool idea of
wanting to bring back uh the dodo bird
and the reason he wanted to do that was
as a symbolic gesture to remind people
about biodiversity loss so thinking
basically explaining the this huge
process that you'd have to go through
and we'd have to do this and we'd have
to do this and we'd have to do this and
then finally we would get something that
looks like the doo but I think there was
one other type of tiger maybe that he
was thinking about doing it with uh and
then to basically use that as the tip of
the spear to say do you see all of this
work that we've just had to do to try
and bring this bird back to life like
just try not to try not to kill it this
time type thing yeah I mean it's it's a
little bit the same story with with
forests where I think we often think
about like planting trees and regrowing
forests whereas like the best thing we
can do a forest is just like not to cut
them down in the first place and to some
sense it's the same of biodiversity
where you know it would take a massive
effort to be able to bring back a
species or even restore a population so
they you know obvious best thing is like
not to to push it to Extinction in the
first place what about ocean Plastics
I'm aware that microplastic like we can
Alex Jones our way into phalates and the
water all that we want but ocean
Plastics I'd heard this story about this
island the same size as Texas that's
somewhere and it's swirling around and
and then there was that guy that made
the the ocean scraper thing and and he
was doing he was doing really great work
but what's the what's the story there
with ocean Plastics yeah I mean I don't
I can't solve the plastic problem like I
I think plastic is a really tricky one
it's like a really amazing and valuable
material which I think is why it's we
produce so much of it and it's so hard
to get off of it um but the the simple
problem of like Plastics flowing into
the ocean is a very very like tractable
one uh we do have significant amount of
plastics flowing into the ocean like the
latest estimates are like around 1 to
two million tons a year now for
perspective that's about
0.5% of the
plastic uh waste we produce so I think
the notion that you know all of our
Plastics are flowing into the ocean is
not correct like it's a quite quite a
small percentage but in in absolute
terms it's quite big um the key problem
with plast plastic ocean Plastics is not
necessarily using plastics it's like how
they're managed so if you can um store
Plastics in landfills or they're
recycled or they're incinerated then
they don't Le leak out into the
environment and they don't end up in the
ocean rivers or ocean the problem is
often that um in many countries the
waste management infrastructure is not
there to to to deal with the amount of
plastic that's there such that it's
often dumped or it's in an open landfill
and blows into to the ocean um now I
think it is a I mean to some extent that
then is social is quite simple like and
it's not sexy it's just like build
landfills or build Waste Management
structures but like that doesn't tend to
get a ton of investment because it's not
like flashy um but there is also
projects trying to do the opposite one
is as you said it's a guy called ban
slat and he created the ocean cleanup
project where they are basically trying
to scoop plastic out that's already in
the ocean and get it out and I think
they're doing a really good job I mean
they haven't got all the plastic out yet
but they are being quite successful in
getting some of it out and then they've
also generated a kind of separate
project which is trying to stop it going
into the ocean in the first place so a
lot of this waste tend to come tends to
come down through rivers and what
they've done they've like modeled to try
to work out like what are the biggest
rivers that are contributing to the
ocean Plastics then they have what's
called an Interceptor where they
basically try to like stop the Plastics
going in at the end of the river before
it reaches the ocean so I think there
are I think he's done an amazing job and
he's kind of came out of nowhere and
decided I mean we all just watch and say
oh that's really bad that there's
Plastics in the ocean and he's like no
there doesn't have to be Plastics in the
ocean and he's kind of tried to to
engineer a solution out of it have you
got any idea which were the rivers that
were contributing heavily I mean it's
changed a lot that our understanding has
changed a lot over time I think
initially you know there was estimates
that you know most of it was coming from
like 20 Rivers now actually that's quite
good because then you only need 20
interceptors but I think more recent
Studies have shown actually it's coming
from like a thousand different Rivers um
which is a much trickier problem to
tackle like most of these
Rivers uh from the latest study from you
know Bo and SL slat and his colleagues
tend to show that a a lot of them tend
to be in Asia or South America or Africa
they tend to be in Middle inome
countries where um people have got
richer they're now using much more
plastic but again the waste management
infrastructure hasn't managed to catch
up rich enough to buy the things that
are in the plastic but not rich enough
to be able to work out how to deal with
it once you've used it right exactly
what about over
fishing
um they are
um again there's a little bit of a split
where over fishing is a tracable problem
it is a problem that you can manage um
the key for that is being able to
balance fish population such that you
know how much you can catch without
massively reducing the population of the
fish right you want to be in a state
where um for fishing you're fishing um
and the population is not decreasing now
if you've overfish so if you fish too
much that population will start to
decrease and decrease and decrease
actually even for from an economic
perspective that's only good in the
short term right because in the medium
to long term the amount of stuff that
you can fish will just decline over time
so it's like a really shortterm benefit
for a medium to
longterm uh detriment now many regions
fish populations are actually doing fine
because we can do that quite well and we
have policies in place and quotas on how
much fishermen can catch in other parts
of the world that's just not there um
and you would expect often that the the
fish po populations there are are
declining so the estimates that are
around around a third of the world's uh
fish populations are being
overfished now the there is a slightly
different story to that where in the
past you know our only way of having
fish was to like catch wild fish what
we've seen over the last few decades is
the rise of what we call aquaculture
which is fish farming now um a little
bit like on land where we would normally
just hunt animals we then decided no
we'll grow animals so we'll have
livestock and we'll raise our own
animals uh that's kind of what fish
farming is all about where rather than
only catching Wildfish you basically
Farm your own fish and actually now fish
farming uh produces more than wild fish
so most of the growth in in global Fish
Production over the last few decades has
come from fish farming it's not come
from Catching
Wildfish it seems to me like thinking
about all of the stuff that we've spoken
about today this tragedy of the commons
thing really just comes back to the four
that we are individual Nations who are
not always even coordinated internally
but definitely not coordinated
effectively externally between all of us
and that by trying to improve the
quality of the shared environment that
requires different actors and agents to
behave in different ways and it can feel
to some like they're having the brakes
pressed on them while other people are
getting away on a free ride you've got
this free rider
problem how do
you how like how do you suggest that
especially developed countries that are
going to have to potentially go to their
citizens and say hey your quality of
life is going to stagnate or or perhaps
even get more difficult more expensive
more whatever um have you thought
around necessarily from a public
messaging standpoint but just like
culturally how do you deliver this
message to people because we're not it's
not in our nature to say oh like sorry
the people in Chad or or or Zimbabwe or
whatever need to have better access to
whatever don't don't worry people of
Chad like I've got you like that's just
not that's not in our nature and it's
very difficult in age of the internet
and sort of quippy sound bites and Tik
Tok length videos it's way too nuanced
and subtle to get across but the
alternative is to kind of use a more
doomsday scenario which kind of just
blanket coverages everything with fear
and Terror and that also is not only not
accurate but doesn't necessarily have
the desired outcome so have you have you
kind of conceived this what a what a
like climate culture 3.0 would look like
yeah I mean I think I think part of this
has gone come down to the fact that I
think we've often not been very good on
our messaging on this I think coming
from and I'm part of kind of the
environmental movement I think often
it's framed as a sacrifice right it's
like you have to sacrifice this um in
order to solve this problem and I think
again again I think in the past that
might have been true um I think the only
solution in the past would have been you
just have to use less energy and you
have to have less stuff and you have to
have it's all about less less less less
and I think we're moving to a stage with
the development of many of these
Technologies where you can switch and
it's not necessarily less and it's not
necessarily a sacrifice it's just better
right so there are Technologies where
you could actually just reduce energy
bills you could create employment
opportunities like in many of the these
growing Industries like they are
creating a job boom and they are
creating employment opportunities you
could get lower energy bills the cost of
running your car would be lower on
electricity so I think there are a range
of solutions there where it's not
necessarily a massive sacrifice it
actually can just benefit and and
enhance life so I think we've done quite
poorly on the messaging on that because
it's all been about less less less
sacrifice sacrifice sacrifice I think in
terms of the role of rich countries and
how they contribute to this uh dilemma
in lower income countries is that I
think the responsibility of rich
countries is they they need to get their
emissions down first and foremost right
they've had high emissions in the UK
we've had high emissions for a really
long time we've managed to get to a
stage where we're rich um we have really
high living standards and in some sense
I think it's just a responsibility to
get our domestic emissions down but I
think the role that they all rich
countries can also play is that they can
also be the drivers of innovation and
deployment of these lowc carbon
technologies that we need and these tend
to follow what we would call a learning
curve where s solar or batteries or wind
for example the more you deploy them the
low the price gets so it's like a
self-filling trend where deploy more
prices fall deploy more so what what
that means is that by um pushing these
Technologies and innovating on these
Technologies we basically drive down the
cost for the rest of the world so we can
we can we can invest money we can deploy
them we can make solar batteries
electric vehicles really cheap such that
people in lower income countries don't
need to face that trade-off anymore they
can develop they can follow um a path
way to a really high standard of living
but they won't follow the pathway that
the UK or the US uh followed because
they won't have really high coal
emissions they won't necessarily drive a
petrol or a diesel car so I think that's
the the big role that rich countries can
play and again I don't I don't think
it's necessarily this big sacrifice
that's often made out to be what about
China obviously it's often brought up in
this discussion as a country that is
quite developed but also I have no you
will probably know how much truth there
is in it they built more coal plants or
whatever plants in the last however many
years than so on and so forth the point
being that the that the Free Rider of
Free Riders would be China what what's
the truth about that I don't think
China's a free rider I think it's true
that they are and they produce they're
the highest Amit and they produce a lot
of coal um and they are still building
coal plants but I think the the kind of
paradox there is that they are actually
just leading completely on low carbon
Technologies like they're building solar
and wind so fast they are uh pushing
really hard on electric vehicles so the
biggest uh car electric car company now
is not Tesla but byd which is a a
Chinese company um they are dominating
the supply chains for these minerals
they are they are seeing this as an
economic opportunity and in some sense
they're going to start pushing a lot of
Western manufacturers out of the market
Market because they've been sleeping um
and I think that's the kind of General
trend of where that's going so China is
deploying these Technologies really
quickly as an example last year China
produced or or uh installed enough solar
and wind to power the UK or France and
they're adding that in one year um so
they are building this stuff very
quickly and to the extent we are and
we're really bad at predicting Peak so
I'm not going to put a definitive Peak
on it but some people have been talking
about whether China's emissions could
Peak this year or next year just because
they're building low carbon technology
so quickly so that's the Paradox of
China or like they are still producing
lots of coal but they're also really
leading the way on low carbon
Technologies again not necessarily
because they really really care about
climate change they're doing it for the
economic opportunities they're doing it
for employment There's an opportunity
there um which to me in some senses are
positive right because it's really hard
I would love every one to be really
passionate about climate change but
that's just not the reality so you need
to create other incentives for people to
act and the the key point there is that
people will just act because it's
economic to do so and you get the side
benefit of yes we reduce carbon
emissions and we also reduce air
pollution so for me in some sense that's
also a positive yeah I mean this seems
to be the kind of like one of the I
don't know one of the the laws of
physics of of climate change or of of
impact it in an effective way which is
show me the incentives and I'll show you
the outcome you know before Tesla came
along at least in the west driving an
electric car wasn't a status symbol so
the incentive of I want to buy a vehicle
that I look cool in and it gives me
Prestige and people think that I'm like
trendy or whatever for driving it wasn't
happening so much with a Prius it was
like a political statement to drive a
Prius was a political statement um
whereas if you can make the thing that
you want people to do also the thing
that they want to do then you're
swimming Downstream and yeah totally if
if this is the way that it is and if
getting reliable energy from solar from
wind from other stuff I've heard a lot
of criticism around the reliability of
it Germany's problem that they've had
where they've had to like retrofit gas
and then obviously they became super
dependent on an area of the world that
was dominated by a war for two years and
then that meant that their prices were
going up and all the Germans going to
free in the winter and all this stuffff
um but presumably all of these are just
I would imagine teething problems that
are only going to be made by one country
and moving forward it's like H don't do
a Germany like if you ever make yourself
into you know like one of those quotes
that's if you've memed yourself into an
energy uh energy strategy that's
probably a bad idea but yeah if we can
get it to the stage where it's both more
economically viable and also impact the
environment in a positive way that like
that's literally the best if if the
people that we and I know I've been
super critical of China but I do
sometimes find myself like leaning into
the they're almost like immoral it's
like an immoral country somehow and that
you know that they um because they're
antagonistic or adversarial with the
West that they're doing things to try
know they're completely disregarding the
environment like that's not necessarily
the case like so I need to kind of fact
check my thought check myself and I do
do that but the point being that we
presume China has more priorities than
simply the climate and yet if they've
managed to build sufficient renewable
energy to power the UK or France in the
last year go okay that if if we can
encourage them to do it then countries
that are part of the G20 or whatever
other
organization it should be pretty easy
yeah I think there I think there's I
range of examples that like I in the
book I give an example of like on a
personal level like my brother now my
brother bought a Tesla and he didn't buy
a Tesla cuz like he really really cared
about climate change he just put a Tesla
cuz a Tesla was cool and it was a really
nice car to drive like he sat on one and
was like this is the best thing ever I'm
going to get a Tesla and obiously
massively cut his carbon footprint but
it wasn't necessarily because of climate
I think another like clear example there
is that like in the US there's obviously
there is a very quite strong partisan
divide on climate where like left a Pro
climate policies and a lot of people on
the right are are less so but then you
look at what which states in the US are
producing the most Renewable Power and
the top five five states with the
largest amount of wind in their energy
sector are all Republican um and again
they're not doing that for climate
they're doing it just because land
owners can make money there's an
Economic Opportunity the community
starts to get behind it and actually
when you look at kind kind of messaging
around climate in these kind of contexts
um the language you use is so important
so if you just talk about clean energy
many more people are behind it like on
the left and the right everyone loves
clean energy um what they don't like
necessarily all like is talking about
climate and actually you ruin the
chances of the clean energy being
deployed if you try to push the climate
message too far so I think really
gearing the climate message to like
whoever you're talking to is so
important if you're talking to someone
that's really Into Climate Change of
course talk about climate but if you're
talking to someone that's a bit
skeptical but they they're pretty in
favor of clean energy then you actually
can actively push them away from it if
you try to force the climate message too
hard yeah use the right language with
the Right audience very interesting
let's bring this one home Hannah I
really appreciate you for today where
should people go they want to keep up to
date with all the stuff that you do why
should you send them um I have a
newsletter called sustainability by
numbers and I try to break down all this
stuff by numbers um I have a new book
out called not the end of the world
where I discuss all of this and then I
work at our and data where you can find
like all of this data and research on
how all of this stuff is changing hell
yeah thank you Hannah thank you if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe